I can't go into the world and be
creative and do my work if I don't have
support for my husband but now Reese
Witherspoon and Jim Toth are going their
separate ways the couple share one son
Tennessee James born in 2012. I'm from
Tennessee Rhys also has two kids Deacon
and Ava with ex-husband Ryan Phillippe I
just think the most important thing is
that you figure out what your kids are
passionate about sort of encourage them
to be the best versions of themselves
recent Ryan Who Fell in Love on the set
of Cruel Intentions split in 2008. I
have to say I'm old enough now to know
that I don't know anything about love or
relationships I mean I think as you get
older you realize I thought I knew
everything and now I know nothing so I
just you know I just try to go with my
instincts her instincts led her to
talent agent Jim Toth they announced
their engagement in 2010 after less than
a year of dating
[Music]
the two said I do in 2011 at her Ranch
in Ojai California just a few weeks
before will and Kate you were so excited
last time you were here about the royal
wedding and then since then you actually
have gotten to meet both of them I did
and my husband just thought it was so
dorky he's like why are you so excited
so often people feel broken in life
through life experiences and to know
that you can actually save yourself it's
sometimes that's all we have and that's
a great thing after tying the knot Reese
who wasn't getting the kinds of roles
she wanted took a suggestion from her
new husband you read more than anybody I
know why don't you try to turn some of
these into movies that led to her
producing and starring in Wild
my pack oh man
the adaptation of Cheryl stray's Memoir
which chronicled the author's own next
chapter landed Reese her second Oscar
nod she should just get a proper
housekeeper you're very short excuse me
she became a Powerhouse behind the
camera developing TV hits like big
little lies and more high profile
adaptations for the big screen don't
tell me I could never do anything I
couldn't start a company I couldn't
climb a mountain I couldn't have three
kids if I didn't have a supportive
husband and he is my biggest champion
and my biggest fan we're enjoying
ourselves it's all a family affair
E.T caught up with Reese who was still
wearing her ring at the premiere of
Daisy Jones in the six in February it
was soon after she wrapped filming the
third season of The Morning Show another
Reese Witherspoon production three words
to describe this season uh
just drama
Romance
um
just all the feels
[Music]